hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about quadrant streak also known as the
streak plate method before we get
started make sure you find the url in
the description below where you can find
a bunch of free study notes including a
picture of the finished board with all
the notes filled in and also remember to
subscribe so let's go ahead and get
started with the quadrant streak it has
two major purposes the primary purpose
is to isolate
a pure
culture so pure culture of some
microbial species almost always this is
some bacterial species because as we see
it's necessary for the growth to kind of
stay in a local area and to form
colonies and bacteria do that well this
is usually for bacterial species
and it's to isolate a pure culture
from
a
mixed culture of multiple species so
basically how do you go from a plate
that looks like this that might have
multiple bacterial species on it maybe
even like some you know some mold that's
what i drew in red right there
and how do you go from that to a petri
plate
a petri plate petri dish that is a pure
culture where everything growing on it
is the same species that's what the
quadrant streak is for the secondary
purpose is really about maintaining that
pure culture
so a quadrant streak is also used
to maintain a species in pure culture
for lab uses or for further study in my
micro class i have students they go out
and they swab
something in the environment and they
get plates that look like this
and then they have to take
individual colonies from here and make a
quadrant streak to get that pure culture
and then throughout the semester they'll
continue to do what we call subculturing
meaning they're taking
colonies from a plate that's kind of
gotten old where the growth isn't very
healthy anymore and they're moving it
over they're doing another quadrant
streak to kind of revive that culture
and keep it keep it fresh basically
so that's the sort of the secondary
purpose in general though if you're
asked for the purpose on an exam the
primary purpose is the one you want to
give to isolate a pure culture
one species from a mixed culture
now ultimately how you do this the goal
is to spread what we call the inoculum
that just means like the the single
colony that's picked up and moved over
the goal is to get all of those bacteria
from that one single colony
spread out and i'll talk about how to do
that in a second
but to spread the inoculum the contents
of that single colony that you're trying
to grow in pure culture
over the surface of the auger usually in
four
sets
of streaks
one per quadrant
and this is
where the method takes its name
so if you look at some of the streak
patterns i've got here
i've got you know three different ones
drawn up here all of these are good so
i've got a check mark here
different people will have different um
sort of different
patterns that they like to use i think
this is the one you see most commonly
like in the textbook where you've got
four sets of streaks and the goal is to
is to get bacterial growth that looks
like this
some people will use kind of a quadrant
pattern like this i actually like to do
this one where you see i've got a fifth
set of streaks not exactly a quadrant
anymore but i'll pull a fifth set over
into the center just to use like all of
the available space
and to increase the likelihood that i do
get
you know colony growth and not just
bonds
so spread the inoculum over the surface
of the auger usually in four streaks one
per quadrant to spread or thin it out
to result in
well-spaced
colonies
and to do this with aseptic technique
that is without introducing
contaminants
so again when i do this with my students
i want to see
you know actually i have a rubric that i
grade their quadrant streaks on and one
of the things on the rubric is that they
have to use
most of the surface of the auger
another thing on the rubric is that
there need to be
well-spaced colonies you know these
right here these up here they're
they're not
as accessible as the ones down here so
the goal is to get
somewhere in the streets and sometimes
students if they've taken just a very
small colony sometimes they have
well-spaced colonies here and they have
like hardly any growth down here at all
others they've got lawns lawns lawns
lawns and it's maybe only in that little
fifth set of streaks that they get a few
a few colonies in there and it just
depends on how large the original
inoculum is and how good of a job
they've done it spreading it across the
plate
and then of course also on that rubric
is about contamination i want to see no
contamination for a full score
so now let's kind of take a look at the
procedure here pretend that you've got a
mixed culture maybe it's a mixed culture
because you've taken some kind of
environmental sample
or maybe it's a mixed culture because
you were trying to grow something in
pure culture but you've got
contamination in there
either way
you can
take the colony that you care about the
species that you care about and move it
over onto another plate perform a
quadrant streak or sometimes i just call
it a quad streak
to get your pure culture
and so how do you do this well the
procedure is to start with a sterile
loop
this might be like a sterile plastic
loop that you've ordered from a company
or it might be a wire loop that you
sterilized in a bunsen burner but using
a sterile loop to select one colony i'm
going to put that in here right here
one colony remember the goal here is to
get a pure culture if you select more
than one colony
and you are getting especially you know
the two colonies are two different
things then you're not going to get a
pure culture so use a sterile loop to
select one colony
then you make each set of streaks now
this is the really important part
you've got to start
each set of streaks
by contacting the previous streak
so what does this mean
in order to spread things out and in
order to go from lawns to sort of a lot
of of closely clustered dense colonies
to well-spaced colonies you've got to be
spreading it out getting kind of less
and less dense with each quadrant
so
pretend like this is my loop okay and
i've sterilized it in a bunsen burner it
glowed red hot i wait for a moment for
it to cool
enough and then i want to choose a
colony to start with and i don't want to
choose you know assuming i've got a
bunch of different stuff on here
assuming it's the little bitty black
colonies that i care about i don't want
to try to get that one or that one or
that one because they're so close to
other growth
i want to find the the
colony that i'm going to be able to
select easiest without contaminating my
loop on the other stuff on the plate so
i might actually go for like that one
right there
maybe that one right there
that one right there
just they're kind of easily accessible
so you pick it up with your loop and
then you make i'm going to put a little
one here
a one in a circle you make your first
set of streaks just street street street
streak streak
then if you're using a wire loop you can
re-sterilize it in the bunsen burner let
it cool again if you're using a plastic
loop you can just kind of like flip the
loop a little bit so that you're using a
slightly different surface of that loop
to make the second set of streaks but
here's what i mean by i'm going to give
this kind of a double underline by
contacting
um i'm going to draw an arrow right here
with a star
the second set of streaks starts by
contacting the previous set that's
because you've sterilized the loop again
so you want to pick up
a little bit of bacteria just from from
the first set of streets right there and
then spread it out farther so i would
contact that first
set of streaks one time
and then maybe make a few other lines a
few other lines in that set of streaks
that don't contact the original set
re-sterilize the loop
come back and then do it a third time
but again you're wanting to i'm gonna do
another star here at some point in that
initial yeah the first thing you do in
that third set of streaks i forgot to
label this one's number two this one's
number three the first thing you do with
each set of streak is to make some
contact between the loop and the
previous bacteria that was struck in the
previous set of streaks
so pull that down for a third set
re-sterilize the loop and then again you
know touching the space where your loop
pulled pulled out some bacteria in the
third set you want to
make the fourth set right and i've
already said sometimes i even kind of
squeeze in a fifth set just to make sure
that i definitely am going to get down
to well-spaced colonies
and then once you've done this wrap it
in some parafilm stick it in an
incubator you want to incubate it at the
appropriate
temperature
so basically you know whatever you're
trying to
to grow
it may have an optimal temperature and
you want to set your incubator to that
optimal temperature and then we always
store these in the incubator
up
side
down
upside down that's so that any
condensation collects in the lid of the
plate and doesn't like drown the the
bacterial culture
so that's how you do a quad streak i've
got a ton of playlists that i think
you'll find really useful for your
microbiology class how to learn all
those micro stains has videos unlike the
gram stain
the acid fasting endospore stains
flagellus stain capsule stain all that
good stuff bacterial growth media has a
bunch of videos on different kinds of
media things like mannitol salt auger
mcconkey auger emb auger all that kind
of stuff and then microbial
sorry microbiology diagnostic tests has
lots of different diagnostic tests
things like the kirby bower test
catalase test coagulase test oxidase
test
all those different tests you'll be
learning about in your microbiology lab
so check out those playlists remember to
subscribe for more free biology study
videos grab that link in the description
box below it will take you to a folder
where you can get a whole bunch of free
biology study notes including a picture
of the final board and that is it for
today thank you for watching biology
professor see you next time